maples and nearby Marco Island
registered Florida's strongest winds
during the storm winds topped out at 142
miles an hour in Naples and 130 in Marco
Island
Jonathan Vigliotti just made it to Marco
Island where yesterday
irma made its second landfall in Florida
Jonathan good morning good morning and
we're taking caution this morning we
were the first news crew allowed access
to the island after the storm hit police
telling us at several checkpoints if we
were to move forward we would be doing
so at our own risk so far we've seen a
lot of downed power lines and fallen
trees we're in front of a hotel right
now where you could probably hear this
emergency siren going off we're told
that it sustained structural damage
police officers actually had their cars
parked outside this hotel and we're told
by them that those cars several of them
were swept away by the surge irma made
its second florida landfall in marco
island as a category 3 hurricane but it
reached Naples with a terrifying force
the Naples Municipal Airport recorded a
wind gust of 142 miles per hour the
highest reported in the state this drone
footage shows the extensive damage
streets submerged buildings torn apart
neighborhoods littered with debris a
roof completely ripped off it's already
pretty full so we're lucky Julie but
drous Road out Houston's Hurricane Ike
huddled in her closet this time around
she took shelter along with her parents
and hundreds of others at a Naples
Country Club as the dangerous I wall
passed
trees were torn in half and powerlines
ripped down the Naples storm surge
feared to be one of the most dangerous
peaks just over seven feet just half
what was forecast for this area it still
caused devastating flooding for the
low-lying homes and businesses along the
coast telling us they had to carry out
several overnight water rescues again
this area was expecting that storm surge
to be about 15 feet in the end and that
was Jonathan Vigliotti his shot is going
in and out he was saying they're
expecting a storm surge of 15 feet it
was less less than that but still
Collier County which encompasses Naples
and Marco Island about 80% or more out
of electricity they got hit really hard
mm-hmm and as much as you see the best
in people you see the worst I keep
thinking about marks piece where you see
the people looting the tennis shoes I
think that's so disgusting I hope they
catch every one of them but this is what
I like from the Fort Lauderdale Police
Chief
he says going to prison over a pair of
sneakers is it fairly bad is a fairly
bad life decision because as you point
out north there's cameras everywhere so
news crews film that filmed the cars and
the license plates and send it over to
police which i think is great
there you go yeah